my sense is that now they have gone
far too far the offenses they claim have
grown just so bizarre
they say dr seuss wrote books that did
harm that we shouldn't be fooled by his
fanciful charm
but they must assume that we're dumber
than dumb that we'll take their word
just go numb and succumb
but i think they've guessed wrong or at
least we can hope that no one of sound
mind could be such a dope
like everyone else dr seuss had his
flaws he made some missteps he got dirt
on his paws
but he owned his mistakes made amends
and grew wise
illustrated his growth as his heart grew
in size
zeus was a model of how we should behave
in confronting our flaws we should all
be so brave
and if we are able but the lessons to
rhyme for a rhyme drives a point with a
rhythm through time
as for those with an urge to burn
witches and books we should face them
with courage and susan looks
we should block them with baffles that
baffle them good
so our descendants will know where we
stood let them read dr
seuss let them read it i say let them
read the whole catalog
don't you take it away it's not yours to
take it belongs to us all
your authority is fake and your bluff we
now call
straight to hell with this wokeness kids
can handle the truth
acquisition of nuance is the purpose of
youth if we shield them from slight
strabs and bumps they'll grow
weak they'll fear violence and innocent
words that we speak
and who wants to live as a quivering
wreck minds like a sieve hiding under
the deck
have them come out stand up tall and
robust
although history's full of events most
unjust that's not the whole story
no not by a lot we've made progress a
plenty in both fairness and thought
though we've miles left to go and no
time to rest
the west is best suited to master this
test
so we must protect it stand fast and
defend
values that must never be brought to an
end equality is good
a most worthy objective it must be
defended from naive invective
now we must keep on and continue to
strive to keep progress going and keep
hope alive
doesn't matter your color your sex or
your creed opportunity is the thing
all sneetches need irrespective of stars
that they have or they don't
regardless of things that they will or
they won't we know how to fix this
it's in all those books lodge now deep
in our minds and the crannies and nooks
have a look and you'll see seuss is in
there i swear
so give him a good dusting off if you
dare he taught us a lot that we now need
to know
how is it he knew all the places we'd go
i'll now leave you with this just one
final thought i'm aware of the hard
place in which we're now caught
and i've noticed the rock that is
blocking our exit i know all about trump
and joe biden and brexit
i've read about covet and lockdowns and
masks in light of all that i've just
one simple ask can we please cut it out
and not cancel and mock
can we team up together to dislodge this
rock
because we do need to exit this
historical phase
do you get it yet or must i rephrase
we're all in it together
you can like that or not bound up as one
we will prosper a rot
we have one tiny earth it's all that we
roam
that's what astronauts tell us upon
returning home
and i'm sure that they're right as i'm
sure you're aware so treat this rock and
each other
with the greatest of care
[Music]
you